hey what's up guys my name is Archana
and were about add Android support for
the Sparky game engine so tomorrow
morning in about 12 or so hours from the
big from the time of this video gets
released I'm gonna be live streaming a
lot I'm gonna start a huge live stream
in which we're going to basically add
Android support for the Sparky game
engine so Sparky currently has zero
Android support it's completely Windows
only there have been some kind of I've
set some things up to kind of maybe
allow Mac to be integrated easier and
Linux as well but absolutely nothing to
do with mobile platforms that's for sure
so we're going to basically take the
Sparky game engine and make it run on
Android and support Android properly
okay
so that's gonna be a blast if you guys
are interested in that which I know you
are then you're gonna want to watch that
livestream so to make sure that you
don't miss it
I've prepared a little countdown timer
on live.com I haven't used this website
in ages but I thought that I'd i crack
it out for this so if you if you are in
doubt as to when the livestream is gonna
be it's gonna start at 10:00 a.m.
Australian Eastern Standard Time on
Saturday the 10th of September I believe
it would be and like if you're in any
doubt as to when left the livestream
starts just go to live Delta trainer
back home and there's gonna be a
countdown timer as you can see which was
which is like is it is it's a countdown
timer right it doesn't care what time
zone you're in it's just counting down
so that you weren't actually miss when
it starts the livestream of course will
be on twitch.tv 4/2 Cherno i always do
that that's my main twitch channel if
you guys don't know that's where I want
to be streaming and we're gonna be
putting Sparky to Android right there
now if you can't make the livestream for
some reason and it would be on like all
day cuz this is gonna take me a while
possibly even Sunday as well I'll keep
you guys updated but if you miss the
livestream for whatever reason do not
worry because I will be posting the
entire stream to my channel archive
channel if you guys haven't heard of
this channel it's just YouTube duck home
for slash journal archive right there'll
be a link in the description of this
video as well I post all of my live
streams here as they are from twitch
like I literally just export them from
twitch so the whole uninterrupted live
stream will be on this channel go ahead
and subscribe if you want to not miss
that as well and yeah so I mean I
there's gonna be a lot of work
I can tell you right now the the way
that we're going to basically do it is
we're going to be using
Nvidia's Android or what's it what is it
called our code works they've changed
the name so many times I think it's
called card works now officially so
Nvidia's card works tools in fact I
probably got or got inside installed I'm
not sure about code works probably yet
and it doesn't work out by the Tegra
tools installed but I'll have to install
them we're basically going to be using
that to get Sparky running where we are
it's not going to be a fully native
application we are still going to be
involving Java as well because we want
to be able to access like Java side
features basically anything is part of
the actual Android API stuff like you
know push notifications or in-app
purchases or really like most of the
controls and stuff a lot of that stuff
actually needs to be done Java side so I
don't want to make this a fully native
application it's going to have a Java
code as well
I'm not just pure C++ but apart from
that it should be a blast it'll
definitely show a lot of you guys how
you can actually get a C++ game engine
running on Android and and overall I am
looking forward to it quite a bit and I
do need to get this done so this is
gonna be it's gonna be good
but yeah so be sure to follow me on
Twitch here and on Twitter as well
because I'll tweet out when I go live
that this time of though is really what
you want to be looking at and the other
thing is I've been I've been posting a
lot of photos on on Instagram lately so
if you guys are interested in kind of
like there's May for example so if you
guys are interested in more than just
programming and you want to see what I
get up to in my life
then go ahead and follow me on Instagram
so anyway tomorrow morning live stream
Android Sparky engine what I hope to do
with this by the way this is one thing
that I'm actually gonna say real quick I
really want to make a series out of this
as well I'm gonna do the live stream so
I'm gonna figure out how to actually get
Sparky thrown on Android first and then
when I do I'm actually going to probably
make a series in which I kind of do it
video like you know almost like a game
programming style series in the sense
that we're gonna be writing all the code
on the actual series right and I'll make
a series of videos on my normal on this
channel of how to actually take Sparky
and like a ready-made game engine
and begin that whole you know how do we
actually you know make it work on
Android how do we add Android support to
an engine that is Windows only right so
that that'll be I think that'll make for
a really nice series so that's that's
where I'm hoping to kind of end up with
this but of course in order to kind of
make that series I do actually want to
like I do actually want to make sure
that I can get Sparky turn on Android
first and so that I know how to do it
and then I can just make a series around
that so that's the idea that's kind of
my end goal here so that's the plan if
you guys enjoy that plan please hit the
like button and leave your thoughts in
the comments below but other than that
I'll see you guys tomorrow morning for
an awesome live stream goodbye